[Musik]
name entscheiden und diplom ingenieur
habe allerdings den beruf des
anlagenmechanikers damals dieser noch
gas und wasserinstallateur auch selber
gelernt und ausgeübt und bin jetzt seit
16 2002 hier in der firma als
geschäftsführer tätig und auch als
gesellschafter mein name ist patrick
hemmer und ich bin anlagenmechaniker
gelernt und habe die ausbildung vor
zirka anderthalb jahren abgeschlossen
in andreas mundt ich komme hier aus
alfter mache jetzt zwei jahren die
ausbildung zum anlagenmechaniker im
bereich heizung sanitär und klimatechnik
ist sehr vielfältig und
abwechslungsreich man kann mit kunden zu
tun hat mit kollegen zu tun und hat im
team zu tun wenn man jetzt auf der
baustelle man ist auch in der werkstatt
die hauptthemen sind natürlich war
sanierung gästen sanierung und im
bereich kundendienst wo kleine
reparaturen gemacht werden und wartungen
an kesseln durchgeführt werden als
anlagenmechaniker ist man viel unterwegs
typische tätigkeiten sind zb
wartungsarbeiten anlagemechaniker
kontrollieren ob die heizung richtig
funktioniert sie machen auch reparaturen
zum beispiel in badezimmern sie bauen
komplett neue bäder ein und installieren
fußbodenheizungen mehr über den beruf
des anlagenmechanikers erfahrt ihr im
nächsten teil